American housing is in crisis.
Right now, up to 12 million Americans are
behind an average of 5,800 dollars on rent
and risk eviction.
With eviction moratoriums soon to expire,
we are facing an unprecedented wave of evictions
and foreclosures that will crash straight
into millions of struggling families across
the country.
But the truth is – this crisis didn’t
begin with the pandemic.
In fact, housing has been in crisis for a
very long time.
Even before the pandemic, in places like New
York[a][b] or Los Angeles or San Francisco,
median rents for even one-bedroom apartments
could approach 2,500 dollars a month – or
more.
About a third of people in Los Angeles spend
a majority of their income on housing.
In New York City, about 20 percent of all
renters pay most of their income to their
landlord.
And in my district, Astoria, about a quarter
of residents have to spend most of their paycheck
on rent.
[c][d]
And the crisis isn’t just in big cities:
in 95 percent of ALL[e][f][g] U.S. counties,
workers making the minimum don’t make enough
to afford a one-bedroom rental on their own.
The Harvard Center for Housing Studies warns
of “a new normal” for housing in the United
States, in which nearly half of all renter
households spend almost a third of their income
rent.
That’s why even before the fallout from
the coronavirus started to hit, more than
half a million Americans nationwide were already
homeless, millions more were on the brink
of losing their housing, and countless families
were struggling every month to make ends meet.
At the root of all this suffering is the fact
that in this country, housing is treated as
a COMMODITY, not a right.
It’s a consumer product, just like clothes
or cars, that private businesses can sell
on the market to make a profit.
And if someone isn’t able to pay – either
because their landlord raised their rent,
or because they can’t work for one reason
or another – they’re not able to stay
in their homes.
If they’re lucky, they can live with friends
or family, or maybe in transitional housing
for a bit.
But for a lot of people, they have nowhere
else to go – and they end up sleeping on
the streets.
In December 2019, the number of people sleeping
in homeless shelters in New York reached 19,000
people [h][i][j][k][l][m][n][o]– an all-time
high.[p][q][r][s][t][u][v][w] 100,000 New
York City students are homeless – that’s
more than 10 percent of the entire student
population.
Why do so many people end up homeless?
It’s not because there aren’t enough homes
to go around.
There are plenty of empty homes.
No.
It’s because housing people IS NOT the primary
goal of developers or landlords.
Their goal, simply put, is to make a profit.
And it’s much more profitable to build luxury
apartments for the rich than decent homes
for the poor.
This gives us a big shortage of homes for
ordinary working people.
For every 100 households that are extremely
low income, there are only 36 affordable and
available homes.
As a result, we have plenty of housing for
the rich.
But poor and working-class people don’t
have nearly enough on the market.
So we have people scrounging to make ends
meet or sleeping on the streets right below
luxury condos and uninhabited apartments.
This is a TERRIBLE way to organize a housing
market.
It might be profitable for landlords and developers,
but it’s not efficient or beneficial for
the rest of society.
In fact, housing doesn’t have to be seen
as a market AT ALL.
In other countries, housing is considered
a fundamental right, like education or healthcare.
That means the government goes to significant
lengths to guarantee everyone has a home,
and the market plays a much smaller role in
the construction and distribution of housing.
So let’s hop across the pond – and about
100 years back in time – to take a look
at just one example of how an alternative
housing model got started, in beautiful Red
Vienna.
At the end of the First World War, the Austro-Hungarian
Empire collapsed, leaving behind a number
of successor states – including modern-day
Austria, home to the former imperial capital
of Vienna, the fifth largest city in the world.
Despite being the seat of an empire[x][y],
the chaos of the war and decades of neglect
had left the working class of Vienna in desperate
circumstances.
Inflation was rampant, jobs were scarce, social
services were non-existent, and hundreds of
thousands of people were crammed into decaying
tenements where overcrowding, disease, and
violence were rampant.
So it’s no surprise that in 1919 – at
the first elections ever held in Austria where
all adult citizens could vote – the Social
Democratic Party swept into power at the municipal
level on the promise of dramatic social and
economic reform.
And they delivered.
The new government of Vienna implemented a
huge range of services, including public healthcare
and public childcare.
They built high-quality hospitals, schools,
and recreational facilities.
But their crowning achievement was an ambitious
program of social housing, what Americans
call “public housing,” that began in 1923
and saw sixty thousand new apartments constructed
in the first year of its existence – built
by the government and financed by taxes on
the rich.
[z]
But these weren’t the kinds of apartments
you might picture when you think of public
housing in the United States – drab high-rises
plagued by chronic neglect and underinvestment.
Residents could enjoy leafy courtyards, wide
open spaces, and plenty of natural light.
They had shared laundries, state-of-the-art
kitchens, food co-ops, bathhouses, pharmacies,
lecture halls, schools, and swimming pools.
These apartments were designed to be both
beautiful to look at and beautiful to live
in, fostering a sense of shared community
among the people who lived there.
And the best part was that because the city
didn’t have to worry about making a profit,
just about paying off their maintenance costs,
these homes were both much nicer AND much
cheaper than what workers had previously known.
In 1926, the average rent in Viennese social
housing was about FOUR PERCENT of a monthly
wage.
The first fifteen years after Austrian independence
saw its capital transform from a symbol of
urban blight into a beacon of socialist governance.
It became known as “Red Vienna,” after
the official color of the socialists who had
pioneered these changes.
And even though Red Vienna fell in 1934 when
the country was seized by fascists – who
did what they could to roll back social housing
– that commitment to good, cheap housing
remained after the Second World War.
Today, an astonishing 62 PERCENT of all city
residents live in social housing, with the
average monthly rent falling somewhere between
400 and 600 dollars a month, with subsidies
for lower-income tenants.
That’s a FRACTION of what people in America
pay.
Unlike in the United States, where public
housing is treated as a worst-case way to
house the very poor, Vienna’s social housing
residents are extremely diverse.
Everyone except the top fifth of the population
is eligible to live in social housing.
This means there’s broad appeal across many
segments of society – which creates the
foundation for its political popularity.
THAT is how the majority of people in Vienna
enjoy something that’s considered almost
utopian here in New York: affordable housing
that isn’t just cheap, but DESIRABLE.
Housing that isn’t just four walls and a
roof, but a real home – with a sense of
stability, safety, and community built in.
Now, of course, this is only one example of
an alternative framework for housing.
And Vienna has not fully removed housing from
the domain of the market.
Residents still pay part of their earnings
in rent to cover operational costs, and a
sizable chunk of the population lives in private
housing.
But it’s an actually-existing alternative
that shows us what a step toward a better
world could look like.
If we want to end the housing crisis, the
solution has to be moving toward the full
DECOMMODIFICATION of housing.
In other words, moving away from the status
quo – in which most people access housing
by purchasing it on the market – and toward
a future where we guarantee high-quality housing
to all as a human right.
So, how can we do it?
We can start by making sure people who access
housing on the private market have ironclad
protections against abuse and exploitation:
preventing landlords from increasing their
rents too sharply, requiring that evictions
be approved by a judge, and giving tenants
a right to renew their lease.
But to go further, toward the Vienna model,
we’ll have to go beyond the market.
We can establish community land trusts to
gradually buy up housing on the private market
and convert it to community ownership.
We can give tenants a right of first refusal
to buy out their landlords when buildings
go for sale.
And we can fully commit to a new era of social
housing, ending subsidies for luxury housing
development and using our wealth to build
beautiful, high-quality social housing projects
that offer good homes and strong communities
to everyone.
We won’t decommodify housing overnight.
But we know what we have to do, and we have
history to guide us.
And we know how we'll get there
Through the movement of the multi-racial working-class
organizing for the better world we know is possible.
And we've already begun
I’m Zohran Mamdani, Assemblyman for New
York’s 36th Assembly District in Astoria,
Queens, for the Gravel Institute.